salut habituellement le mardi je fais un
tour à quelqu'un je mentalise quelqu'un
mais un événement m'oblige à changer le
calendrier de la chaîne aujourd'hui
puisqu'il ya quelques jours dans les
commentaires de la vidéo numéro 163 je
lis un petit pavé intéressant et là
c'est le drame
j'hésite d'abord à répondre longuement à
ce commentaire et je me dis il ya
peut-être mieux à faire répondre
publiquement par vidéo puisque peut-être
que d'autres personnes pensent la même
chose donc j'ai demandé à l'auteur du
commentaire si je pouvais le prendre en
photo pour le publier dans une vidéo il
m'a dit ok lisons le ensemble je me pose
tout le temps la même question quand je
te vois tu exténué c'est pourquoi tu
fais ça ok quand bien même que réussi à
faire une vidéo pendant un an tous les
jours quel est l'intérêt j'avais pensé
au début que c'était pour augmenter son
nombre d'abonnés mais au bout de six
mois la progression n'est pas très forte
prends ça je veux bien que tu fasses ça
par passion mais bon est-ce que ça en
vaut vraiment le coup même si tu réussis
et que c'est une victoire personnelle
tu auras perdu tellement je pense que ça
doit te coûter de l'argent de faire des
vidéos tous les jours et par dessus tout
du doit consacrer un temps fou pour
faire ça à temps que je un temps que tu
aurais pu passer at amusé à à prendre du
bon temps à te détendre je n'incite pas
arrêté il peut quand même non je ne
décide pas arrêter youtube donne la
juste peut-être éventuellement de la
possibilité que d'arrêter ce challenge
est de faire de trois vidéos par semaine
comme ça tout le monde est content tu
aura du temps pour toi et on aura des
vidéos de très grande qualité même si
pour la plupart le sont déjà
donc merci merci parce que c'est pas du
tout agressif comme commentaire il n'y a
pas de souci je comprends ce que tu veux
dire d'une envie de répondre en vidéo à
tous ceux qui pensent la même chose que
toi ou en tout cas certaines parties je
reprends le point par point
déjà le mot exténué alors j'ai peut-être
l'air fatigué dans les vidéos c'est avec
des fois je suis fatigué quand je fais
parce que je filme tombe matin ou tard
le soir
mais le reste de ma journée je te
rassure ça va je ne suis pas xt minute
par contre ça m'oblige à avoir un rythme
de sommeil où je dois faire un petit peu
attention puisque sinon je me crève vite
c'est vrai dans le temps c'est déjà
arrivé avec les dates de tournée en même
temps que que j'étais un peu ko parce
que j'avais pas anticipé les vidéos
elles avancent maintenant je fais plus
la même chose quand j'ai des choses très
conséquente de prévu sur un deux ou
trois jours en général des dates de
tournée donc alors je prépare quelques
vidéos à l'avance quel est l'intérêt de
faire une vidéo par jour pendant un an
si ce n'est le défi personnel
alors contrairement à ce que tu pensais
c'était pas forcément de gratter un
nombre d'abonnés plus grand parce que
mon
objectif à la base était d'avoir douze
mille abonnés à la fin de l'année si je
parle d'objectif en terme d'abonnés
disons que je m'étais dit six jours au
moins en moyenne 1000 abonnés par mois
ça va il ya quand même des gens que ça
intéresse mais l'objectif n'était pas de
grossir comme ça le nombre d'abonnés tu
vois je suis au moment je fais la vidéo
je dois être presque à 16000 donc cet
objectif là est largement dépassé mais
l'objectif premier c'était de me
stimuler à écrire dans l'une des
factures explique que j'écris mon
nouveau spectacle en ce moment qui va
sortir en janvier les prochaines sur une
tournée de rodage où il ya déjà 80 dates
de calais plus après festival la venue
en 2010 est plus encore d'autres choses
derrière et le fait de m'obliger à
sortir une vidéo par jour pendant un an
je suis obligé d'aller d'aller puiser au
fond de moi-même pour trouver des sujets
abordés des des idées des choses que je
sais que j'ai oublié ça me permet aussi
de voir les sujets qui vous plaisent le
plus ou pas pour voir si je les aborde
dans mon spectacle pas ça m'oblige à
créer des tours et des effets pour après
les amener peut-être différemment sur
scène ça m'oblige à créer du matos en
permanence sur scène quand on monte un
nouveau numéro on dit concrets du
nouveau matériel
en faisant ça en faisant ces vidéos je
suis en train de créer un matériel
monstrueux ou en tout cas une prématière
que j'aurais pas forcément trouvé tout
seul devant la feuille blanche durant
les séances de travail et en ça c'est
merveilleux je regrette pas du tout si
j'avais annoncé que je faisais deux
vidéos par semaine ou une vidéo par
semaine je me connais je pense que
j'aurais pas forcément tenu mais j'aurai
forcément trouvé une bonne excuse à un
bon moment pour commencer à décaler à
décaler le fait d'annoncer publiquement
que je m'engage à faire une vidéo par
jour je sais ça par contre que je ne
lâcherai pas parce que il ya aussi
légaux qui jouent derrière et je veux le
faire je veux réussir ça donc est ce que
ça vaut vraiment le coup oui quand bien
même je continuerai à fermer 300 vues
par jour comme je faisais au mois de
janvier
je serais quand même très content de
faire ses 300 villas les personnes avec
qui je discutais dans les commentaires
mois de janvier je vous retrouve encore
oui boulaq est là dans les commentaires
des vidéos aujourd'hui sur facebook sur
twitter sur snap
il y en a certains d'entre vous qui sont
venus me voir en spectacle je trouve ces
relations la géniale donc ça vaut le
coup ça vaut le coup et puis il ya tous
que ça amène à côté aussi toutes les
personnes que j'ai rencontrées en plus
l'autre jour je vous ai fait une vidéo
sur la zone de confort c'est exactement
ce que j'ai fait j'en suis sorti donc je
rencontre de nouvelles personnes à
nouvel univers nouvelle manière de
penser
d'autres choses aussi que ça amène jeu
train de faire des vidéos pour le groupe
d'ailleurs pour leurs chaînes notre
famille points comme ça c'est les vidéos
du mental blog qui m'ont amené cette
proposition là donc je te le dis je te
le répète ça vaut le coup ensuite tu dis
que peut-être j'aurais perdu tellement
perdu beaucoup peut-être aussi que vous
derrière votre écran vous dites ça que
je perds beaucoup à faire ça alors en
termes d'argent je ne perds rien
réellement d'ailleurs je ne gagne rien
ou en tout cas pas grand chose pour être
très honnête avec vous je fais 150
dollars de revenus youtube par mois dans
ma société donc ça veut dire qu'une fois
les charges passées les impôts société
si je vous le transformer en s'attaquant
s'avère n'être il va me rester à peu
près 50 euros je paie personne matériel
que j'ai ici c'était du matériel que
j'avais déjà et effectivement le seul
investissement réel que je fais en
permanence et l'investissement de mon
temps personnel
alors pour ça aussi géruzez c'est à dire
que je me lève un petit peu plus tôt
qu'avant et je me couche un petit peu
plus tard qu'avant donc je prends sur
ces moments là est des moments où je
geek et où je glandouille et où j'étais
juste sur l'ordi à rien faire c'est à
dire même pas à jouer ou à faire un truc
intéressant à rien faire ces moments là
je les ai rapprocher je les ai condensé
et c'est les quatre à six heures que
j'utilise par jour pour faire mes vidéos
des fois c'est un petit peu plus court
2h30 3h et en général ces quatre heures
donc je passe autant de temps à m'amuser
m d'étendre à passer du bon temps je
sors encore le soir je vais encore mes
amis mais oui le rythme est plus soutenu
plus dense mais je les mets je le gère
je crois intelligemment
donc je n'arrêterai pas de faire les une
vidéo par jour parce que ça m'apporte
beaucoup ça m'apporte aussi dans la
relation que j'ai avec la caméra n'était
pas quelque chose sur lequel j'avais
l'habitude avant même exprimé face à une
caméra je sais m'exprimer sur scène mais
pas forcément devant un objectif
maintenant je crois que ça commence à
s'améliorer
par contre il ya deux choses que je peux
vous dire par rapport à tout ça c'est
que oui l'année prochaine verra moins
deux vidéos et on n'aura pas une tous
les jours mais justement pour leurs
raisons que asie va invoque c'est à dire
j'aimerais faire moins de vidéo mais un
peu plus poussé un peu plus riches aussi
en terme de contenu en terme de décor en
termes de sujets que j'aborde en terme
de montage de réalisation donc il y en
aura forcément un peu moins mais elles
seront mieux écrite est mieux produite
bon en attendant il reste quand même 200
vidéos du mental le gars faire est la
seule question je me suis vraiment posé
sur laquelle asie va pas tout à fait
tort c'est toute l'année est ce que
c'est intéressant alors l'était pas
forcément parce que l'était apparemment
il ya beaucoup moins de personnes qui
regardent youtube c'est plus le même
rythme les youtuber aussi sur un petit
peu
tous mus en pause quoique l'année
dernière les questions qu'on faisait
toujours une vidéo par semaine elle
était toujours aussi bien alors moi je
veux pas mais souffler cet été je veux
pas non plus cramer des sujets hyper
intéressant que vous allez pas trop
regarder parce que elles seront pas
produite au bon moment donc je commence
à avoir des idées il y aura sûrement un
ou deux formats un peu spéciaux qui
j'espère vous plairont pour cet été ou
au moins durant le jour entre le 15
juillet et le 15 août
on va voir comment on va s'organiser
mais je vous en reparlerai juste avant
asie va merci beaucoup pour ce
commentaire qui m'aura permis de faire
cette vidéo et puis aussi moi de prendre
du recul par rapport à la chaîne et de
me poser des questions en dix ans et
s'il avait raison
et peut-être que vous aussi vous vous
posiez tout ou partie des mêmes
questions que pose et asie va et comme
ça je vous ai répondu aussi en même
temps merci beaucoup d'avoir regardé la
vidéo vous êtes comme ça ne change rien
la chaîne c'est aussi grâce à vous
qu'elle tient et que je suis toujours
hyper motivé à le faire
rassurez vous je ne suis pas épuisé de
toute fatigue vous pouvez laisser un
petit commentaire en bas si c'est pas
déjà fait vous pouvez vous abonner à la
chaîne puisque le mental blog asie
valady c'est une vidéo par jour pendant
un an donc rendez vous demain à 17h ciao